Part of how I parent as a cycle breaker parent
is overcompensation for the things I did not get in my childhood,
which may or may not be detrimental to my own children
in its own weird way. I'm very aware that I have an anxious attachment,
so I tend to be over protective of my kids.
I tend to be concerned that
if they're off doing something by themselves
that they don't know that I love them.
I wanna make everything special and important
and child centered and magical for them.
I constantly tell them that I love them and that I'm proud of them
and they're the most amazing thing in my entire universe.
And so
I wonder if the trauma that they will receive from me is smothering,
because I received the exact opposite of smothering from my parents,
I was damn sure that the one thing that my kids were gonna know
is how much I love them and how important they are to me.
And I wonder how many of us overcompensating parents,
Pinterest moms, people setting up balloons for every single event,
every single birthday morning,
making pancakes the shapes of bunny rabbits.
All of us were killing ourselves to try to be a perfect parent.
I wonder how many of us are doing it because we didn't get one
and we wish we had had one
and if we would still be perfect to our kids.
Probably would if we did less.